the first Hobbit film is finally here
guys we have been watching my previous 3
reviews you know I'm a big fan of the
Lord of the Rings I love that original
trilogy I think it's one of the best
trilogies ever made so let's talk about
the new film The Hobbit The Hobbit and
unexpected journey is once again
directed by Peter Jackson and this is
the prequel to the Lord of the Rings
trilogy this is the film that shows how
a lot of the things that happened in the
Lord of the Rings trilogy is set up but
it's mainly the tale of this one little
innocent Hobbit played by Martin Freeman
who goes on an adventure with the wizard
Gandalf played by Ian McKellen a lot of
dwarves underground in which he first
discovers the ring a dragon Gollum and
many other things and this is our first
look at a brand-new j.r.r tolkien
adaptation adventure now I gotta be
honest with you guys I like to keep it
real you know I've been hearing things
about this movie I was hearing it wasn't
as good as the original trilogy I was
seeing a lot of reviews saying the first
hour was a little bit hard to get
through and so I didn't set myself up
for disappointment I went into the film
with low expectations I loved the
original trilogy so much but I went to
this film expecting to not be blown away
and just be like okay let's just watch
this movie and see what it's all about I
didn't want to hype myself up too much
because whenever that happens it always
leads to disappointment and I'll be
completely real with you guys I'm not
gonna sugarcoat this at all this is
nowhere near as good as the original
trilogy now if you didn't like the
original trilogy then you're not gonna
like this film it's not gonna convert
you it's not gonna change you this is
not as good as that original trilogy no
I don't want to be that god just sits
here and compares it to the original
trilogy the entire time because I'm not
gonna do that I'm just gonna tell you
that it's not on that same level
unfortunately there are a lot of
problems with this movie but there are
good things too for sure there's a lot
of impressive things in this movie
namely the acting very good on almost
everyone's part Ian McKellen is Gandalf
I just it's so good to see that
character back he is awesome and he's
excellent here you can't really imagine
that character as someone else he plays
that kind of grandfather role just
perfectly where he's calming and you can
tell that he really cares about these
people but he's also a complete badass
in battle which is pretty awesome now
out of all the actors perhaps the most
important piece is definitely Martin
Freeman as the Hobbit and his character
at first is very kind of a little bit
prissy you know he wants his dish
kept safe don't touch my carpet and all
that stuff you know that's how he is at
first and throughout this series I'm
sure we'll see him mature more but in
this first film it does take a while for
him to kind of get more into the idea of
an adventure and that leads me to my
main issue with this film and that's the
pacing the first hour to maybe even 90
minutes of this film
our little rough not too much happens
and you may be getting ready to tie it
while that's how it is in the book Chris
well you know what when you adapt a book
to a film there are certain things that
can be omitted and there are certain
things that can be left out because they
don't add anything to the movie and
they're more to enrich the novel
experience when you adapt a book to a
movie certain things need to be cut out
so the pacing can flow better because
the first hour to 90 minutes of this
film were pretty much a snail pace and
something no one's running around being
chased by trolls or anything I'm not
talking about that it's just it's not
terribly interesting for this first hour
to 90 minutes that's because the
characters and the dialogue there wasn't
too much going on it was a lot of
exposition and for that reason I had a
hard time getting into the first act of
this movie once these characters start
on their journey it does pick up a
little bit but there are hitches along
the way where certain scenes just don't
feel like they need to be there and that
was pretty disappointing because it felt
like the adaptation of the book was very
literal like this is exactly what
happens and we're going to tell it and
it came off as kind of like the extended
edition blu-ray was being shown in
theaters where it should have been you
know deleted scenes that were shown on a
blu-ray for the hardcore fans of the
film and I feel like since I kind of
have an inside track on the way this
film was made how it originally started
out as two films and midway during
production was extended to three it
seems like a lot of scenes that would
normally have been removed from this
film were included to extend the film's
runtime so they could make a trilogy it
really feels that way when you watch
this movie because there's a lot of
scenes where at the end you're like did
that really add to the movie or was that
just there because it was in the book
another problem we have this film and a
problem that a lot of people are going
to have trust me is radagast the wizard
this character is extremely annoying he
is basically the Jar Jar Binks of this
movie and gratefully he has nowhere near
as much screen time as charge our Binks
did but this time they
he does share in this film leaves you
wondering why he was there and why they
took him in that direction he's going to
be a character that many people are
going to not like or some people are
gonna love me like why don't why do you
like and is gonna be websites probably
called kill radagast calm it's gonna
happen trust me this character is pretty
horrific ly annoying and I couldn't
stand him gratefully he's not in the
movie for too long let's talk about some
more positives Thorin
the main dwarf that guy is awesome he is
fantastic in this film and he is kind of
like the Aragorn of this movie his dwarf
had the most depth out of all of them
had the best back story had the most
fleshed out of a character and you
really felt for him the most
as the dwarfs that leads me to an issue
I had since there are like 13 dwarves
it's really hard to kind of care about
them all you know it's like certain ones
are just gonna have to fade out into the
background because when I think about
this movie I'm not really thinking about
these characters it's more of Thorin
Bilbo and Gandalf and these three
characters are the ones that really
progress the film along the rest kind of
feel like baggage at times I got to be
honest but let me tell you about the
best part of this movie for me my
favorite scene in this film was Gollum
and Bilbo and the riddles that they told
one another down in the caverns that was
brilliant I could have watched that
forever I serious that was the best part
of this movie and really the last hour
of this film is what I wanted the entire
film to be like because it's not a bad
movie at all don't get me wrong it is a
enjoyable film I think a lot of scenes
that could have just been omitted and
just taken right out of this movie I
think if this was a two hour movie it'll
been pretty awesome I saw the film and
48 frames per second 3d the 3d is
immaculate it looks incredible the frame
rate is so amazingly vivid that that 3d
really helps however the 48 frames per
second is going to be extremely
distracting for many people myself
included the first few shots of the
movie where people are walking around it
honestly looks like some sort of quick
twitchy robot when Bilbo was puffing his
pipe it's like really awkward it just
looks so strange there are certain
overhead battle scenes that look really
impressive with everyone running around
you can tell this looks real you know
but there's just something extremely
distracting about it to the point where
it takes away from the movie going
experience unfortunately and actually
became a bit of a negative for me so I
would recommend seeing the film in 24
frames per second first and then going
back and then seeing it in 48 frames a
second time just to experience it
because it's interesting it's something
new it's something to look at and you
can decide whether or not you like at
first but it honestly was so distracting
for me and a lot of other people in the
theatre said the same thing nevertheless
the finale of this film is extremely
enthralling the acting is good Gollum is
amazing the CGI looks fantastic Howard
sure once again delivers a very great
musical score it's just that first hour
to 90 minutes is a little rough and
that's coming from a huge Lord of the
Rings fan I gotta be honest with you
guys I got to keep it real with you guys
I'm not gonna say what you want to hear
there are problems with this movie it's
not perfect however I am optimistic the
next few will be better and I hope that
they take the advice for many people
that I'm hearing about omitting certain
scenes that don't really need to be in
the film even if they're in the book
this is an adaptation of a book to film
and it should be treated that way I'm
gonna give the Hobbit a b-minus which
unfortunately is a lot lower for grade
than I wanted to give so if you've seen
The Hobbit yet what do you guys think
about it I'm gonna be doing a spoiler
filled review with my buddy John the
flick pic we saw it together that's
gonna be posted later this weekend look
forward to that as always guys thanks a
lot for watching and if you like this
then you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes